[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joined today by eric debra ocheri
all the way from ghana through our
partnership with the center for advanced
studies and behavioral sciences
eric has been studying the way work and
sonic spaces come together
through his work at the university of
cape
coast where he is the chair of the
department of music
and dance welcome eric deborah ocheri
thank you very much xender for the warm
introduction it's really an honor to be
part of the longbow talk and
i'm happy for the invitation now
think for a moment about the sounds that
people make when they are involved in
physically
exacting activities weight lifting
martial arts tennis tag of war
you name them sounds such as ah
well these answers are universal
sometimes
these sounds are even involuntary
monosyllabic
most of the time actually non-lethal
because they are not words
that you can look the meaning up in a
dictionary
but these words are functional these
sounds
contribute to the total achievement of
the goals of the work
these sounds are evolutionary
adaptations
think for a moment about what happens in
the human gas exchange process
when we breathe in or we breathe out the
production of these sounds such as
these sounds that accompany manual labor
or when people work and these sounds
that come out
these sounds they require contraction of
the diaphragm
which pushes out steel or deoxygenated
air
from the lungs quicker than would happen
in normal breathing
at the same time the open mouth allows
for a bigger swoop
of oxygen intake which gets into the
bloodstream and supports the muscles
involved in the execution of the task to
function more effectively
the timing of the sound is equally
important they occur at the point
when the assertion of the energy is
needed the most
that is at the individual level
individuals
involved in hard tasks and making these
sounds but what happens
when the work involves a coordinated
effort with more than one person
making the sounds at different points
will definitely result in noise
which will be counterproductive exerting
the energies at different points in time
will lead to less productivity
synchronization then becomes very
necessary
sounds are synchronized to provide
reference points
for the assertion of energies which
result in higher productivity
i mean you can think about the one two
three heapho
or such other verbal cues that call on
people to coordinate the efforts and
apply their energies at the same time
synchronization of sound for extended
periods after all
appears to be a unique human trait
now imposing some kind of order on the
sound
which is the pitches in time
which is rhythm is perhaps the minimum
definition of music
the contents described show how people
use sound
or how they constitute sonic spaces how
they pace themselves within these sonic
spaces that they have created
in order to attain the most of a
specified activity
it is quite easy to assume that the
ultimate function of music
at least in the context of group work is
to provide reference points
for synchronized activity right about
now
i think it's important to have a look at
some of these songs
and what i'm talking about
[Music]
obviously there is a large body of
examples to draw on
when it comes to music and work ranging
from cooperative singing in the work
that requires coordinated group activity
for example fishing
farming pounding through religion music
in the context of marketing and consumer
behavior
to technologically enhanced more
personalized use of music such as in
in the use of headphones while jogging
or learning while engaging some kind of
cognitive activity there is quite a
substantial amount of literature that
exists on work songs in general with
that label
are labor songs occupational songs
incidental music
depending on the author these names have
been used interchangeably
and the sources include
ethnomusicological accounts
travel literature anthropological
writings slave narratives historical
accounts
archival materials the work of
psychologists and scientists
mates and legends i mean the sources are
many folklore
biographies and memoirs labor union
writings archaeological evidence
business tracts speculations of
philosophers sociology song books
recordings and so on all these are
sources resources
that have documented what the label of
work songs are
and i'm careful in this presentation not
to use the label wax songs
for a number of reasons that i will
explain later
today's presentation i am trying to use
and focus on aspects of my field work
that are based on group music making as
evidenced in the songs of indigenous
cyanide fishermen
in ghana they go back many many many
generations into history
centuries because of this they offer a
good platform to interrogate
the changes that happen over time the
repertoire
has influenced over the years other
musical styles
and has also been influenced by same
we are possibly staring at the final
moments of some of these
singing traditions and so there is a
need to start from there
to learn as much as we can from them and
record it for posterity
before it totally disappears
these are fishermen examples of the
songs that they sing along the shorts
when they are engaged in their work
ghana is a west african country bordered
on the north by burkina faso
the east by togo in the west by cote
d'ivoire
and then in the south by the
northeastern most part of the atlantic
ocean
the gulf of guinea which borders the
southern part
of the country the southern part
the coastal stretch is about 528
kilometers
and her boss about 200 communities whose
indigenous occupation
is fishing and fishing
not in a very mechanized sense but
especially in the traditional sense
where they use local materials that's a
sign net that they go out the drag net
they go and cast the net and then they
come ashore and
for hours they pull they try to pull
this
net as shown so as i mentioned there are
about 200 communities that are involved
in this small scale
artisanal fishing it employs about 10
percent of the population which
according to our last census
estimates about 3 million people the
fisheries
sector accounting for about five percent
of ghana's agricultural production
in all there are many many ethnic groups
in ghana
but the dominant ethnic groups that
populate these shores as i mentioned are
four
and and they are positioned mostly
in four of the administrative regions of
the country namely the volta region
being the border of ghana with togo
greater accra region which is the
capital of
of ghana a central region just the
colonial capital city of of ghana
and then the western region which shares
a border
with cote d'ivoire and within these
regions
are ethnic dominant groups
so the ever people populate the the
voter region
the ghana populate the greater accra
region
the fante subset of the account group
they populate the central region
and then we have the enzyma who
populates the western region
so here is an example of a song sung by
a migrant community every community
um living in a via crow a
a village close to the university of
cape coast
and the title of the song is amalekum
this indigenous fishermen in many of the
coastal towns they used to propel their
canoes and boats
through manure west who sang as they
rode to the sea
now because of technology and because of
modernization
many of them have bought and adopted the
use of
outboard motors and because of that the
place of the manual rui which
involved the singing and the musical
practices has now
changed and so a lot of the repertoire
that was used for
rowing has now found its way into other
repertoires
many of which have now found their way
into the repertoire of the pulling song
and not
the ruling songs and this is one of the
reasons that
i dare say that we are probably looking
at
one of the last generations of this
fishing tradition
so what they do now is they go and cast
the net
a few hundred meters uh from the shore
in a loop
they come back to the shore and with the
help of the side nets and ropes
very long ropes they pull their they
pull the cash
ashore and this is always done to music
so in this presentation i'm going to
talk about
um the songs that the fishermen employ
in executing their work and i'm going to
do so
using three main dimensions what the
music says
in terms of a symbolic and referential
meaning
what the music does in terms of his
pragmatic and functional meaning
and then what the music is in terms of
its aesthetic
and non-referential meaning the main
approach to studying these
songs fishermen songs has been a
polyvocal ethnography approach
on-site recordings at the shore where we
record the music in the context of the
work but also bringing them to the
studio
and then we do the initial sorting and
teaming and we go back to do interviews
and
feed the themes that we have analyzed
into the interviews in order to gain
a deeper understanding of the work
so i will just start first from what the
music says
in terms of the referential and symbolic
meaning
and here emphasis is on the words the
lyrics
perhaps the sounds can distinguish
between two main kinds
of of of text in the songs one
which are less words which from the
majority of the songs about 85 percent
of them
you have you know lesser call words
which are used and these are words
with specific meanings in the language
in the dominant language
in which the music is sung and then we
also have a good number of non-lesser
car vocalizations
these are sounds like what i intimated
earlier
which have no meanings in themselves in
terms of
a dictionary definition but which are
used a lot which find their way
in the music proverbs
anthropomorphisms idiomatic expressions
illusions
metaphors repetitions personifications
xeomorphisms anthropomorphisms and and
on and on
a lot of literary features literary
devices
and these are markers of a very
sophisticated culture because of these
features the construction of
meaning from the test is very delicate
and complex
over time these fisher folk have
developed a kind of sub language
which i referred to as the fish's tongue
now the distinctive
distinctive features of the fish's
tongue lie more in the manner in which
the words are articulated
than in the laser cone itself the manner
in which they mention the words and the
structure
of the phrases it's quite difficult to
understand
even for so-called native speakers of
the dominant language
who are not the fish who are not part of
the fisher folk so in general
many of the west sound muffled
consonants are attenuated or elited
words are deliberately used in contests
which are in congress with the regular
language
many of the borrowed words are
deliberately misappropriated or should i
say appropriated
so that even when one recognizes the
language
from which the word was borrowed the
words do not necessarily mean the same
thing
in the fischer's tongue furthermore
several words are leading with
ambiguities and are often interspersed
with jargon
and a lot of non-legitical vocalizations
now this deliberate use of ambiguities
have a purpose
and the purpose is among them
one of what tenor refers to refers to as
multi-vocality or multivocalic
signifiers
the ability to creatively have systems
where you can have multiple meanings at
the same time
and that is a safety feature they were
records that
they repudiability principle it enables
them to speak about sensitive issues and
yet when they are taking on
they can repudiate and say they weren't
even talking about that
and for them this is very liberating
because their work
is along the shores which is an open
space where anybody can go as a public
space
so the ability to create this fascist
tongue and the ability to use
all these features of the language help
them to communicate among themselves
and without the understanding of who are
not
meant to hear so it helps them to
channel the information
uh for for their listeners i would just
like to give one example from the
translations and basically what
what the the lead singer is saying is
that
i am just a simple man singing a simple
song
because i get wet from the sea my sweat
is hardly noticed
i am not the one who made promises for
votes
but when the frog feels the heat from
the pepe
that the lizard has eaten it is worth
talking about
i don't know what i'm even talking about
i'm just singing a simple song
in the second verse of this the singer
goes on to say
i am just a simple man singing a simple
song
because i am not all dressed up in suit
and tie
i am hardly noticed i'm not the one who
traced sex
for favors but when the food is put on
the chair
and the table is used as the seat it is
worth talking about
i don't know what i am saying i'm just
singing a simple song
now in the last line of each of the
verses that i read
the singer says that claims that he
doesn't know what he's saying
but the content of the song is popular
knowledge it is
it is news mainstream news some of it
are political issues
about government appointees who are
appointed on the basis of sex or who
the general public think that they are
not qualified but because of certain
reasons they are appointed
and so songs like this help them to give
and run commentaries about
rather sensitive issues and then because
of these features that i already
mentioned if you take them on
they will say they were not even talking
about that this is the element of
reputability
that i'm talking about so the
development of this unique language
this fischer stone among the fishermen
is a conscious attempt to own their
physical and expressive space
to create privacy in a public domain for
the fishermen it is quite liberating
to build this kind of world where they
freely express themselves
and vent their emotions without undue
interference
the themes of the fishing songs are many
and varied
they sing about family they sing about
love friendship
religion betrayal belief in supernatural
and preternatural powers
death life after death marriage divorce
polygamy
infidelity politics and they chant a lot
of obscenities as well something that
you will not find in the day-to-day
lives of the people so it seems that in
the context of the music
there is a lot more that they can do
which outside of the music you will not
find them doing
and this speaks a lot to leviton's model
in his popular book the world insists
songs he gives reasons
for how music may have evolved and how
it may have insinuated itself in human
health
over centuries and he does so talking
about
mostly emotions and i find that all
these the joy
love comfort knowledge religion
friendship are reflected and deep seated
in the kinds of music that are being
sung
a lot of the content the lyrical content
they have types of
typologies having sort of sort of
essential labels of
of what they are who they are without
and
as being a conservative people without
any conscious
attempt at actually getting out of this
and the songs
and the content of the songs reinforce
these kinds of social labels
the types of workers personalities and
their conservative
they enact the same scenarios fitting
themselves within these rather
essentialist frames and reproducing a
sense of false identity
or perhaps living to fit within these
established
frames by so doing attitudes to world
view
gender relations uh sustainable
development belief system are reinforced
and are entrenched in the music
of of of this fischer foe so many of
them have even the belief that if you
are rich you don't have to show it
because
then other people in the community can
can harm you
and so they continue to perpetrate this
idea of poverty
of course it is not to say that all is
rosy and many of them
actually not canoe owners so there are
people who own the canoes and who
own their fashion equipment but they do
the work and they have to account
and the owners of the canoe who are the
supposed rich men
they become richer because when the
share the catch is divided
they get a bigger portion of it so they
have a lot of songs where
they criticize these but in a very
subtle way
because they also don't want to lose
their jobs and music offers them
that space to vent all their
disagreements and
all their brought up emotions there is
an example of a song
that shows the state in which the
fishermen find themselves the kind of
negative negativity or the negative
balance as i mentioned
and this one is entitled money no they
come
[Music]
on
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm going to talk about the non lesser
kai expressions for a minute
that why there are so many at the
beginning of the speech
i gave sort of a scenario about how
the attempt to synchronize the
individual sounds may have actually
resulted
in music and group singing but the
purpose of these non-lethal
vocalizations
do a bit more than i mentioned earlier
among other things
these functions they buy time while they
the workers think about new songs to
raise so in that
sense these are gap fillers they add
some kind of comic relief
in the way that they are uttered and
they are vocalized
they help to provide a steady tempo
encouraging group participation
here is another example of songs
basically highlighting
the use of the non nonlexical
vocalizations as i mentioned
and how they provide the reference
points for coordinated activity
okay
so actually if you analyze the songs you
will realize that
all these non-lethal vocalizations are
those ones that occur
at first intervals and it is actually
these ones
that establish the pulse in the music
and that helps to provide
a reference point for the coordinated
activity the parts that
um let's call where they overlap and the
cross
they overlap and they are actually not
in line with the tempo of the work
itself so the non-laser cut
vocalizations are short repetitive
and they keep the pulse of the work
going
and they provide a steady tempo in
addition to this
it helps to provide more participation
because it
is very simple all you need do is hear
it
once or twice and you can join it
doesn't require any
prayer rehearsals that means that in the
work that requires a lot of
hands when the song is not too
complicated
it becomes easier for other hands to
join in and sing
and join them and pull the work make the
work easier
so the coordination covering up coded
messages
and most importantly increasing the
output of the work
are some of the functions of the
non-laser car vocalizations
i will now want to speak a little about
what the music is
the efficient songs that are sung
actually reflect the identities
of the musical identities of the major
dominant ethnic group
among which the fishermen are located
so among the ever you find markers
of every musical identity among the guy
you may find same
among the account and so on so it
follows
the structures dominant in the ethnic
groups that are involved
most of the songs are percussive and and
this is achieved by the use of these
non-legitical vocalizations that i
mentioned and
this is also may be informed by
ecological factors
in southern ghana there are lots of
trees and so historically
the musical instruments that are
dominant in southern ghana
are instruments rhythmic instruments
rather than melodic
or harmonic instruments and this finds
this way even in the vocal music
that the people sing so often the music
has rhythmic accompaniments
hand clapping bells bamboo or even the
side of the canoe
or idiophones and so on most of the time
sometimes when they work you see them
clapping and the clapping is not just to
provide accompaniment to the singing
and the clapping is also a way of
getting their hands off momentarily uh
from from the ropes which is quite uh
hard and which which can actually scar
your palms
and when you have the sand getting
attached to the ropes
it becomes very very um painful to pull
so when they clap or when they do some
of these other activities
through the music they're actually not
just entertaining themselves
but they're actually helping to
complement and make the work
a bit more easier in terms of toner
organization
the music is based mostly on parallel
octaves which are sung in unison and you
have occasional cadentia parallel
thoughts and fits
in the voice part typical rhythmic
patterns as i have mentioned
imitate the main rhythmic patterns of
the musical styles of the dominant group
so overall most of the songs have a call
and response
form and it's quite sung in quite a
playful
manner in a style that has many
unintelligible sound now the playfulness
is not to say that they are talking
about subjects which are not
serious they're actually talking about
very serious subjects
but they do so in a playful way in such
a way that
they don't stir up too much anger among
them
most of the songs have frames and so
the singing and enactment that you find
at the show are actually representative
of the happiness within the communities
themselves
now these frames help people to openly
express themselves
by alternating the test of the core part
with current issues of concern
in a very satiric manner in this sense
the song serve as
a kind of moral control a tool to keep
each other in check because if you know
you
if you mess up you know that you mess up
or you do something that is not
uh approved in the conventional sense uh
norms of the society it will find its
way in the songs the following morning
and everybody you know will know what is
happening or what you have done
in that sense because they know there is
this kind of check
it helps with moral and behavioral
control
some of the songs contain sexually
explicit and evocative words
these are not a la these are allowed in
the context of the songs
as long as they remain at the shore in
the contest of work
and hence this is why the sonic spaces i
mentioned becomes very important
because when they leave their shows
these same people will not even want to
think about
such things and they do not encourage
the use of
profanity or chanting of
sexually explicit content but in the
context of the song is
it's quite liberating and they're able
to do that and they chant it
all the way but the language is all
involving
uh because of the many years of working
along the shore
um the fanta group the girl group ever
groups
they have cross paths and these days you
find a voice almost at
along the shores of all the parts of
ghana and where they find themselves
in a predominant ethnic group that
becomes a place for actually
interrogating how the languages and the
cultures
mix because within the songs within the
compositions itself
you find identities and markers of one
ethnic group
using the musical markers of one ethnic
group but using
the language or the test of another
ethnic group
so the the music of the fischer folk is
characterized by
skillful spontaneity of organized sounds
they create with tests and they conform
to the tonal inflections
of the groups there are a lot of
rhythms rhythmic alterations that happen
although we have a steady pulse that
might be identified
but we have a lot of endemic alterations
because of the multiple voices
that they hear at the same time and
there is room for a lot of improvisation
descriptors as i have mentioned they
evoke
some kind of within standing conclusion
so what is music for them
what is music doesn't mean that anything
else is music well
need to be considered as long as it
bears a kind of family resemblance
to other examples that are generally
agreed to be music
what does the music do i'll speak lastly
on the pragmatic
or the functional meaning of the songs
up until now the function of the music
has been
filtering through my talk in a number of
ways
in the context of work a key function of
the music
is to help them increase productivity so
that is the core
among the facial folk this happens
through the provision
of reference points for synchronized
activity
but quite apart from that all the other
things that the music helps
to accomplish have to do with the
music managing or triggering
the emotions of people and what the
emotion can help
to achieve so if the music helps
to excite them in a way that is positive
and they get positive outcomes in a way
the music
serves as a space for repairing
relationships
there are examples of songs when people
vent
their misgivings as part of the work as
they work
they vend their misgivings and there are
actually
times where you can find somebody else
retorting
but all through song and if you are just
a casual observer
you might not notice this this might
totally elude you all together
but in the context of song they repair
the broken relationships
and they forge stronger social bonds so
there are a lot of implications i can
think of
for crisis of music for starters this
the repertoires are actually finding
their way into other musical modes which
are
which are more current so how some of
these repertoires have found their way
into other musical practices which are
very common uh today
and how they are using technology to
modify some of these musical phrases
but quite apart from that in terms of
the function to which the music is put
and in terms of music helping to
regulate emotions
or help to manage emotions that is still
very much so
uh in the use of music in other contexts
when people
for example are running or reading and
walking their dog
when people want to get themselves
elevate themselves into certain states
which help them to be more productive
they use music and perhaps these
examples are like
antecedents of this kind of practice
just not in
in the communal setting but more
individualized uh use of
of that i'm going to pause here for a
minute and then
if there are questions that come up then
i can use it to elaborate further on
some of the points
that that come thank you thank you eric
that was really fantastic uh i'd love to
invite you on where you're joining us
all the way from
ghana where we'll be pre-recording this
q a
to make sure that uh that our
connectivity is good and we're able to
get to all the questions welcome eric
deborah o'terry
thank you so much xander my pleasure
you bet well thank you very much for
doing this i know it's uh it's tricky to
do at this great distance
um and you're one of the partners uh
that we have through kazmis the center
for advanced studies and behavioral
science
uh with uh with with stanford and the
um i just wanted to talk to you a little
bit about your experience of being a
a fellow um during this you know very
strange year were you able to connect
with some of the other fellows and
and show your work with them yes yes
very much so
in fact the year at stanford started
quite bleakly we weren't sure whether we
were going to make it
i actually wrote a song about this that
you can hear
sometimes but um we had a very great
support from the caspase team
and they managed to pull it off we
started virtually
and eventually some of the fellows were
able to go to you know
the hill but i couldn't make it to the
hill in spite of that
we had weekly seminars we had lunchtime
seminars we had virtual lunches
um and presentations and
quite some very good interaction with
the fellows
so it was very very worthwhile and
i i got a lot from from the fellowship i
can only imagine how
it would have been like if i had
actually come to the hill
do we know what the earliest uh field
recordings of
of this kind of music is how far back do
the recordings themselves go
uh in terms of the recordings um
i only have um from
the 50s that we have examples but there
are recordings
which are not video recordings that date
back to about
1928 they're about
and we have some of the fishermen songs
filtering into other kinds of the very
early recordings of a ghanaian giraffe
music we call high life
high life music and that is basically a
mixture of
traditional language indigenous language
is messed with
when during the era of colonialism
some instruments such as the harmonica
or the guitar were acquired
and so you have the local rhythms and
the local melodies
being played in a different context with
different instruments
and so basically you have some of the
local melodies traditional melodies
transposing and finding their way into
even the concert halls
and so for from these earlier recordings
there are a few of the fishermen songs
that actually made their way and if you
refer to for example them
uh one of the recordings that that i
you have um you have the examiner
you have that one um so there's a
fisherman's song you
now find it in the contest for example
of a military parade
where you have a brass band playing that
and you
you have it arrangements of that for the
big time coral
choirs on stage with orchestra and and
all that
so we have earliest recordings of these
filtering
in in popular musical repertoires way
back from
1928. i think that's the earliest
recording that
almost essentially so far yeah that i
know about
and what's your understanding of how far
back some of these traditions go i mean
i assume it's thousands of years yes i
could say thousands of years
this particular practice where they go
to sea and they cast the net and they
come back
to haul for hours is
is not the only style of fishing that is
in ghana some of the fishing styles
where
they go to see mostly with the bigger
vessels
and they catch the the fish and then
before they come back to shore
and that doesn't involve long hours of
you know having to use the sinus to
to haul the facial short and so that
doesn't usually have
this kind of singing it may have other
other forms of singing
but the style that we are talking about
now
um that i discussed is believed to have
been introduced by the ever
the ever group and the airways are found
in the
southeastern part of ghana you find them
also in togo and benin
and they are believed to have actually
migrated somewhere
in into ghana somewhere in the 15th
century
and they are believed to have started
this particular style of fishing
and so um i think that at least
if it doesn't go before that it actually
we can trace it back all the way to the
15th
sometime in the 15th century just in
ghana
yeah i think you mentioned a few times
of how these songs cross into taboo
subjects or subjects of you know almost
revolutionary subjects
um and i know that um you know that
happened with some of the african
diaspora
in the united states with slavery that
they were using songs as these kind of
express revolutionary or ideas that they
couldn't express publicly um
can you talk more about how that's you
know what are these subjects is this
is this sexual is it revolutionary or
are these is it is it both
yes that's quite a lot and the music i
should say permeates almost every
every aspect that you you can imagine um
there is a recording we made quite
recently
um along the fishing lines
elsa so it's an interesting story we
went to the show
the local folk when it comes to covet
for example they have a traditional
belief that
along the seashores people don't really
get infected
so among the fishing communities they're
wearing of nose mask and so on
it's not very it's not very common so we
went
to one of these communities to do a
recording and
apparently the crew me and my team were
the only people
really wearing the nose marks so you
could just quite tell that we were not
we're not natives and uh there and then
uh they somebody improvised the song
about kovid and about we
wearing uh you know so
he sang this song and um on the surface
of it it sounded
as if um we heard something
that sounded like he was making a
mistake that he couldn't
pronounce this word as well he was going
between saying corona
virus and colonel bylos
right and um
it's easy to just laugh it off because
you think he's making a mistake but
way after we have returned i i got this
contact
and i've been talking to him and
actually what he's talking about
is actually saying coronavirus on one
hand
and colonial bylaws on the other hand
colonial bylaws and the continuation of
the song is actually he was making
a comment about um
lgbtqi that became a hot topic in ghana
because
they set up offices and we have like a
majority of the population still against
institutionalizing or passing a law to
allow
lgbtq you know ia and and all that
so it's a sensitive area that people
don't really comment on
and so in the context of the song right
what he was
he was doing was interchanging
corona virus and colonial bylaws and
the conversation with him he was saying
that um
the imposition of ghana trying to
implement the lgbtqi
laws is more like being puppets
in the hands of our colonialists right
that we are long past the era of
colonialism but there are people
behind the scenes who are pulling the
strings and so
ghana is trying to dance to their tune
and
and and so you know he was saying
basically
is an insult or an indictment on the
government or those in in power
who are trying to implement uh uh
that or pass a law on lgbt legitimizing
lgbt
you know qri and so ordinarily you won't
be able to say that openly to anybody
but
he says that in the context of song and
in a way that if you were to take him on
he can easily say no i was talking about
coronavirus
but the continuation of the song i think
it would be nice to send you that video
as well
he says coro virus akuro
virus
and then what what follows he says
which literally means that they are
trying to force men
and men to lie you know to lie
and together but we are against that
and we won't do it so he's he's talking
about this
very sensitive uh topic and it was
around the time when the office that was
set up for the lgbtqi in accra
was bent down and so that was you know
so some of these areas where they can
easily you know
um create a song to talk about but
uh quite apart from that they talk about
politics so obviously they talk about
sex they talk about uh
what they believe in the world view what
the expectations of
men and women what you know clear lines
of
inheritance but they also encode
knowledge so uh what is the oral history
of the people
and in song so that if you really
analyze the number of the songs you say
there are knowledge songs there are
songs about where they came from
because now we talk about a lot of
groups that have migrated from one place
to the other
and some of those who are living there
were born there they have never
really gone back to their hometown but
within the context of the songs
if you analyze the test carefully it
means that if they ever have to go back
to their hometown
it gives them cues about who their great
ancestor was and where they can find
what within the community
so in a way they are not just singing
this but is a way of passing down
their their true history from one
generation
to to the other and other things um
you did mention the sexual content
actually
um when they return from the shore from
outside the contents of work and they
come home
there are things that are no do you
never hear from them because
particularly
the men they are the enforcers of of
discipline and one of the things that
they consider as discipline
is the abstinence from
sexual talk pretty much um
so but when they go out and they are
singing
in the context of the work it's actually
they actually have
quite an unbelievably large number of
songs that have you know
sexual subtext and they do that but the
same people once the music is over and
the work is over
it's like drawing a clear line saying
okay that is over now we are home
and we can't talk about some of these
these things
so actually there are a lot of examples
that go
a number of ways right talking about
slavery talking about
um sex talking about politics talking
about gender roles talking about
their oral culture and traditions and
histories and
and so on but also comforting each other
and and and so on quite a number of ways
one of the things you mentioned is that
some of the new technologies of
of you know agriculture as well as
you know fishing is changing the future
of this and
um and looking at your videos there's
there's very few children i noticed
um participating as kind of the next
generation
what's your take on how the next
generation is learning as well as
um how some of these technologies may be
endangering these performance
yeah um i think then modernity has had
its toll
on under singing tradition and um
it it might be fair to even say that
perhaps in the next 10 years
these songs will be very difficult to
find anyway at all
one because of technology and this is
how i see it
so um there is some kind of um
i would say social distinction many of
the fishermen that we find today are
people who
who did not go too high climb high in
the academy in terms of formal
education and so they often see
themselves as
you know lower class or particular class
of people but they are working hard to
send their children now
to school and if you speak to the
younger generation
they help the appearance now to do the
work and
in some of the videos that i send you
may find very little children
involved in the work because this is how
it's an acculturative process they learn
while they are young and then but
many of the youth now if you talk to
them it is not something they would like
to pursue
it is not something that um they would
like to
to do as a career you know like their
parents and so
um just from the interactions with the
youth that is one of the ways in which
we can tell that
this partic not fishing fishing always
will have a future but
life-scale fishing perhaps or different
modes of fishing rather than
this particular type where you know the
music accompanies
the other other form is that um they now
use outboard motors
so they have these outboard motors that
they attach to the canoes
and which they're able to which makes
the work easier particularly going to
to to see because they usually ride
against the waves and it's
it's quite difficult to to get into the
sea
so before for many years they were doing
that with synchronized activity you had
a lot of people
who are to paddle and because
particularly
for the reference point and the
synchronized activities it was fair that
you know they had a lot of songs that
that they used to roll so these were
rowing songs right
now because of the outboard motors they
don't need as many people to go to see
to cast the net
so these days you find three even four
people
just going to cast the net and they
don't do that to music any longer so
that the rowing song the song that they
used to sing when they were robin
you you hardly find them even now in my
field work
we have to assemble the other generation
who knows some of the songs suggesting
these songs to us although they are very
similar
but many of these ruins have now found
their way in the song that they sing
when
after they have gone to cast the net and
they are they are pulling
uh the nets and so you can see that
roaring songs are already obsolete what
they have now is the pulling or they're
hauling songs
right and now with with emerging
technologies there are actually
commercial fishing places where they
they use certain machines to even
uh you know hold the net and if that
catches on
we can say that we may not need as many
people
to to do that work and as long as that
synchronized activity is not um it's not
really necessary then i am
afraid to say that the songs some of
them of course may find their way in
other repertoires but
a lot of them that practice that we are
seeing right now
the music in the context of that work uh
it stands a stands
uh it faces extension imminent extension
and also there is a
rise of multi national fishing companies
you know and they are able to go to deep
sea and they catch
bigger fish and they sell it for less
right so they are also putting uh those
who are doing all these address work
out of out of business so people go to
they have um sale points where if you
want bigger fish and all that
that people go and buy so gradually um
it is not very uh very attractive
let me put it that way and so people are
rather venturing away from that
well i want to thank you so much this
has been uh really really great to have
you
and um i'm hoping at some point that i
can come to ghana
as always that would be nice hopefully
at some point you can come here as well
so it would be great to meet you
most definitely so much
thank you so much and i want to thank
you all for joining us
and i look forward to seeing you at our
next talk thank you